[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: So welcome
again to Google.
We're going to get started
today by just having the cast
members introduce themselves
and talk a little bit about how
you got involved with the show.
DANNY BURGOS: Want to start?
CLAUDIA YANEZ: Hi, guys.
I'm Claudia.
I play Rebecca and I cover
Gloria Estefan in the show.
DANNY BURGOS: How'd
you get [INAUDIBLE]??
CLAUDIA YANEZ: How'd
I get involved?
So I lived in New York.
Just, I heard about the show.
Actually, I used to
sing background vocals
for an artist called Jon
Secada, and he actually
got his career
started by singing
background vocals for Gloria.
And so the Secadas and the
Estefans have a relationship.
And I remember Jon's wife
called me on the phone
while I was doing summer stock
in Vermont, and she was like,
OK, so they're making Gloria's
life into a musical and,
like, you have to try and
get seen, blah blah blah.
But I was not in New York, so I
couldn't audition for the show,
and I moved there, and the
show was already on Broadway.
And I remember I would
literally call my agent
like every other
day, being like,
so when are you going to get
me in for "On Your Feet?"
When are you going to get
And they're like, Claudia,
they are not looking.
And one day, like he emailed me.
He's like, OK, please
stop calling me.
Here is your audition,
blah, blah, blah.
And I was like, thank you, God.
And I went in a ton of times.
And yeah, one day,
I got the call.
My agent was like, OK, you
can finally leave me alone.
Like, here you go, you're
doing the show, blah blah blah,
have fun.
Leave me alone.
I was like, thank you.
DANNY BURGOS: Hi.
I'm Danny Burgos.
I am in the ensemble, and I
understudy Emilio Estefan.
And let me see, my
process with the show
was, I was doing a production
of "In the Heights,"
and I had been asking
my agent over and over
and over again, please
submit me for "On Your Feet!"
And she was like,
I just don't really
think it's the
right show for you.
And I was like, I'm a
Cuban guy from Miami,
how could it not be?
And so yeah, she finally got
me that audition, and I mean,
the rest is history.
I went in for Clay
a bunch of times.
I, like, remember his face
very vividly from my auditions.
And eventually, my
agent called me,
and I was just like,
hi, what's happening?
And she just goes, how would
you like to be on Broadway?
And I was like, what?
And yeah, they
needed me literally
for a month on Broadway to
learn the role of Emilio.
And then while I was
there, they were like, hey,
you're going to go on tour.
I was like, yes I am.
And so yeah, here I am.
MIKE SCAGLIONE: OK.
I'm from Gloria's old band.
I started with her March of
'88, and I didn't do Broadway.
I almost did.
I was still a musical director
touring with Julio Iglesias
year-round.
So I didn't do
Broadway, but then
when the road tour started up, I
was like, yes, I want to do it,
because he stopped touring.
So here I am, and
it's a lot of fun.
We have five guys
from the old band,
and it's like going out and
doing a Gloria show every night
with the energy and these
wonderful people we're
working with.
So it's a blast.
CLAY OSTWALD: So my
involvement with the show
started when the show started.
I was involved with
the very first reading
in New York City in 2014.
I was very fortunate to
have Gloria and Emilio ask
me to represent the music in
the development of the story,
in the development of the show.
So I was involved with
every process along the way.
So I've really learned
a tremendous amount
about how Broadway
works because I'd never
worked on Broadway before.
I kind of got to work
with the best people
right away, right off the bat.
And I never had any
experience at it
before, so it was really
a fortunate thing.
I kind of like equate it to
being on LeBron James' team
but never having even played
basketball ever before,
you know?
So I really learned a lot on
Broadway in the production.
We toured with
Gloria for 32 years.
I've worked with
Gloria and Emilio
as a songwriter, keyboard
player, producer,
and orchestrator and arranger.
So my quick
experience in New York
taught me a lot about
the entire production
and the entire process.
And the musical director
chair, as the tour,
has been a complete joy for me.
I enjoy it very much.
We have a beautiful
band, beautiful cast,
and we really enjoy
doing the show.
SPEAKER 1: That's awesome.
Thank you for sharing.
So Clay, you're from Colorado.
Can you talk a
little bit about what
it's like to bring the show
and music to your home state?
CLAY OSTWALD: Well,
I'm from Boulder.
I was born in Denver.
I grew up in Boulder, and
went to Boulder High School,
and had a great experience
in Miami at college.
But whenever we come
back and do our music
in Boulder, or in Denver, it's
a great experience for me,
because I get my two
worlds to collide--
my youth, my childhood, my
family, and the music of Gloria
and our music from Miami and the
Caribbean in the South America
and all the types of
music that we play.
So it's a real
adrenaline rush for me
to come back home and have
this show, again, represent
and entertain people
here in Denver for sure.
SPEAKER 1: That's awesome.
And so you and Mike have
known Gloria and Emilio
for a long time, correct?
Can you talk about what it's
like to work with them so
closely?
CLAY OSTWALD: You want to start?
So I'll start.
So when I first
met Gloria in 1986,
I had no ambitions of being
in the Latin pop salsa
world of music.
We had a band in
Miami out of college,
and Jon Secada was our singer.
And we had a bunch of great
musicians in the band.
Gloria and Emilio were
just really starting
to make it big in
their industry.
So they came to hear our
band, and they really
liked what they saw, and
they hired five of us
from that band to be Miami
Sound Machine in 1986.
And at that moment, we
were all kind of into jazz,
and we were playing
all kinds of music.
And we thought, oh, this will be
kind of a fun gig for a while.
We'll work for the
Estefans, you know?
And 32 years later,
we're still here.
So through the career of
Gloria and our careers,
there's been so many different
types of genres and types
of music and styles that have
led us in different directions.
So it's also led her
into different directions
as a person.
And she's been so
adaptable and so
wonderful to like take on
these new challenges for us,
and same with Emilio.
And it always gives
us new challenges
and new opportunities to
produce, write, go do concerts,
and have our careers
grow in a similar way.
And now a Broadway show
is an entirely other--
another opportunity for
us that's been fantastic.
Did I miss anything?
MIKE SCAGLIONE: No, you
pretty much covered it.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: And so, Danny
and Claudia, what was it
like for you guys to bring
the story of Gloria and Emilio
to life on stage?
CLAUDIA YANEZ: Well, we
both grew up in Miami.
I was born in Venezuela and
then was raised in Miami.
And so for me, like I grew
up my entire life hearing
about Gloria and
Emilio and, like,
being surrounded by their
music everywhere you go.
Like, you can't walk
into a restaurant
without hearing "Conga."
I mean, it's literally a
part of just life in Miami,
especially because they're
immigrants just like me.
I emigrated from Venezuela
when I was seven.
And so to get to tell
this story in this caliber
and to kind of travel around the
country representing immigrants
and representing this
music that I grew up
hearing is literally
a dream come true.
Like, people always ask me
like, what's your dream show?
What's your dream
role after this?
And literally, this is it.
SPEAKER 1: Aw!
CLAUDIA YANEZ:
Honestly, I'm like,
I really hope something
else comes along
that I love as much as
this, because like this
would be a really--
you know, you hit your peak at
the beginning of your career,
and then you're like, everything
is downhill from here.
CLAY OSTWALD: I'm
not sure they knew--
maybe it was announced,
but I missed it--
that Claudia understudies
the role of Gloria and Danny
understudies the role
of Emilio, so they
go on as Gloria
and Emilio as well.
CLAUDIA YANEZ: Yeah.
CLAY OSTWALD: Yeah.
CLAUDIA YANEZ: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so, I mean, getting to
do that is just ridiculous.
Like especially, I grew up
singing a lot of pop music.
And Jon, who I sang for, helped
write "Coming Out of the Dark"
with Gloria.
And so I remember
being in Brazil
and like singing that song,
singing backgrounds for him,
and then getting to be in
that blue gown at the AMAs
at the end of the show
and, like, lead that song
and lead our company
of incredible actors.
And having the Miami
Sound Machine backing you,
it's a joke.
Like, it doesn't get
better than that.
DANNY BURGOS: I think
my favorite part
of what we do in "On Your
Feet!" every single night is
the fact that we have the
incredible opportunity
as musical theater
actors, singers, dancers
to be playing Latin
American people.
We're not playing a Latin
American stereotype.
American, like, thing.
We're playing these two
pop icons who are Cuban,
and it's just they
happen to be Cuban,
and we happen to be Latin.
And we get to relay this
story around the country.
We're telling people a
little bit about our culture.
And I think that's so
important to educate
the country on what we are.
You know, this is Cuban
culture at its finest,
and it's awesome.
We're representing
people who made it.
They made it, and they're
just Latin people who made it,
and it's awesome.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
The show definitely
had a lot of like
move-your-shoulders-in-your-seat
kind of songs.
Can you talk a
little bit about what
it was like to bring these
kind of international hits,
like the "Conga" and
"Rhythm is Gonna Get You"
and "On Your Feet" to stage?
CLAY OSTWALD: Well,
for me, again, it's
just a really special
feeling to know
that the music that
we wrote, performed,
did so many thousands of times
and did so long ago, still
is being used for something
meaningful and effective and
significant and that matters
to the audience and to the band
and to the cast.
That's really an incredible
thing, that our music--
we thought it was pretty cool
when we wrote it or did it.
And some of it is very straight
ahead kind of dance pop music,
and some of it is folkloric
culturally and significantly
in Cuban, Peruvian, South
American, Caribbean things.
So to have that matter, again,
and be part of a story, for me,
is really fun.
And it really justifies so much
of what we did in our career,
I think.
It's kind of selfish, but it
feels good to say that, yeah.
CLAUDIA YANEZ: It's also
super cool to be onstage.
And as soon as--
for example, when
"1-2-3" starts,
you see like people light
up, and they're like,
I love that song!
But then it also
is kind of a part
of moving our story forward.
Our writer did a
brilliant job and the team
who assembled the musical
did such a great job of using
the music to move
the story forward.
And that is rare in
jukebox musicals, which
is what you call
like a musical that
uses a catalog of music
that already existed.
It's rare to kind of have all
the songs kind of move you
along, but they do, and so yeah.
No, it's so cool to get to see--
especially, the top of Act Two
starts with a medley
of all the hits.
And when you come out of there
and you start singing "Get
On Your Feet" and
people are literally
having to restrain themselves
in their chairs, it's awesome.
SPEAKER 1: What
inspired all of you
to be involved in
performing arts?
Anyone can answer.
MIKE SCAGLIONE: I was a
shy, introverted little kid.
I loved public
speaking, passed out
in my fifth grade class
trying to do a book report.
[LAUGHTER]
Horrified of audiences.
But I just clicked
with a saxophone.
And I did my first
professional gig at 13.
And immediately, I
was like, oh, well, it
seems like all the
band guys are friends.
So I just went into
band in seventh grade.
And by the end of
eighth grade, I
was a professional musician
gigging up to four gigs
a weekend.
And I've been that way
ever since May of 1977.
I'm really old.
CLAY OSTWALD: You came
out of your shell.
MIKE SCAGLIONE: I
came out of the shell.
I just immediately went into
music and just loved it.
CLAUDIA YANEZ: Now look at
you, the life of the party.
Seriously.
I mean, I wasn't shy ever.
Yeah, I've just always
loved performing.
And when I was a little girl,
I would force my parents
to sit and hear me sing.
I was a monster.
But yeah, and as I got
older, I fell in love
with theater, just
the idea of being
able to tell a story
and just kind of connect
with the humanity of the people
that are in the audience.
And I think the theater is
such a beautiful vehicle
to get people to kind of let
down their walls for two hours
or however long the show
is and allow themselves
to see themselves onstage
and to feel something, maybe
learn something hopefully.
So yeah, the idea that we get
to tell stories for a living
is just--
I mean, I don't want to do
anything other than that.
DANNY BURGOS: Let's see.
In seventh grade, I
auditioned for the drama club,
and the teacher told me
I wasn't drama material.
And then in eighth grade,
because I'm stubborn,
I auditioned for the school
musical, which was "Annie,"
and literally four boys
auditioned so I got a part.
And I was Rooster in "Annie."
And Rooster's
first thing that he
has to do when he comes
onstage is crow like a rooster.
And I was so shy
and so introverted
that I was like
[IMITATES WEAK ROOSTER CROW]
and I was terrified.
So I never did
anything musical again.
And when I was 13, I got a
job at Cold Stone Creamery,
and they sing for their tips.
So I got $1 from some guy,
and I sang an ice cream
version of "My Girl."
And the guy turns
back around and goes,
do you want to be in a musical?
And I was like, uh, sure?
And I showed up to the
first day of rehearsal,
and I was cast as the little
newspaper delivery boy
in "She Loves Me."
And the lead didn't show up
for the first day of rehearsal.
So he was like, hey, how'd
you like to be the lead?
And I was like, OK, and that
was my first lead in a musical.
CLAUDIA YANEZ: Can we
please hear the ice cream
version of "My Girl?"
CLAY OSTWALD: So I'd like to
say a quick story about that.
It's kind of fun.
Our family was very
musical, and everyone
was required to at least
learn some music, especially
the piano and some
other music instruments.
And I was always kind of like
surrounded by music in the home
and in the family.
And when I was
growing up, we all
listened to a
certain kind of music
that would just click and kind
of inspire us and get chills
up and down your spine
from some kind of music.
And that feeling about music
was always kind of around me.
And I just want to say a
couple of quick little stories.
One of the first albums
my dad got me for birthday
was Herbie Hancock.
And one of the first songbooks
I ever had, my sister had,
was Stevie Wonder "Songs
in the Key of Life."
And those songbooks
are still in our house,
in my parent's house
where we grew up.
And last week, I
shook hands and talked
to Stevie Wonder for a little
while at our opening in LA
and told him how much his
music meant to me as a kid.
And about two months ago,
I talked to Herbie Hancock
at the honors awards
in DC a few months ago,
and had a chance to
talk to him and tell him
how much his music meant to me.
So I think that inspiration
that you get and the chills you
get from music that matters
is what really motivated me,
and that I still am fascinated
by every night, when we do
the show and we hit something.
And it makes us charged.
And then it immediately
goes out to people
and they let us know how
it makes them charged.
I think that's really important
in the world, that performance.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, I love that.
That's awesome.
So switching gears
a little bit, we
have a couple of more
culturally-centric questions.
The first of which is, although
we still have a long way
to go with the recent releases
of movies like "Coco" and songs
like "Despacito" at the top
of the entertainment charts,
it feels like there's definitely
been a resurgence of Latinos
in film and music.
Have you seen this change
represented in the Broadway
industry as well?
CLAUDIA YANEZ: Definitely.
I think with shows like
"Hamilton" and "On Your Feet!"
it's definitely like torn
down a few of the walls that
were up and now you're seeing
more and more diversity
onstage.
We definitely have
a long way to go,
but it's kind of been
a beautiful thing
to see my peers and my
fellow Latin community
and African-American community
getting roles that have nothing
to do with who you are and
where your background and what
language you grew up speaking.
And it has to do with like
your ability to tell a story
and sing or whatever it is.
So it's beautiful.
Yeah.
It's starting.
Like right now, in
"Waitress" in New York,
there's going to be an
African-American actress who's
going to play Jenna, which
probably two years ago, that
would have never happened,
and so it's exciting.
We have a long way to go.
And definitely, we have to
be super grateful for all
of the actors and the
older singers who kind
of trail-blazed, like Rita
Moreno and all of these actors
who kind of paved
the way for us,
because it's not just
someone writes "Hamilton"
and then all of a
sudden there's-- no,
there's people who like
have been fighting for this
for years.
And so yeah, but
it's definitely--
we're getting there,
slowly but surely.
DANNY BURGOS: I
have such a place
of reverence in my life
for Lin-Manuel Miranda,
because he does
things with theater
that open up these doors.
Like, "In the
Heights" was when I
knew that I wanted to
do musical theater.
I watched those Tony Awards and
I was like, wow, Latin people
on stage doing a show just about
one day in Washington Heights.
"In the Heights" is about
nothing more than just one day
in Washington Heights.
And I used to love things
like "The Addams Family"
where you have like
Gomez Addams which
is a hysterical
character, but he
plays at a stereotype of
what it is to be a Latin man.
And so what I love about
stuff like "On Your Feet!"
we're just Latin people.
"In the Heights," it's just a
bunch of Latin people on stage.
You have "Hamilton," where
you have Angelica, Eliza,
and Peggy, which is a black
woman, a Filipino woman,
and a Latina and they're
sisters because they
say they're sisters.
Yeah, like that's it.
You know?
So what I'm loving about the
way that Broadway is moving
into it's--
I don't like saying
colorblind casting,
because I think that we should
be very proud of who we are
as people, whatever that be.
I think it's more color
conscious casting.
It's like awesome, we're
looking at the fact
that these three women, no,
they wouldn't be related maybe
in real life, but they say
that they're sisters on stage.
They say it every single
time they come on stage,
so let's just suspend
disbelief for a little bit
and for two hours,
they are sisters.
You know?
It's beautiful.
It's really incredible
what we can do when we just
allow things to happen.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
I love that.
CLAY OSTWALD: Can I add
something really quick?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
CLAY OSTWALD: Because I have to.
I can't help myself.
So having the opportunity
to have people
from all kinds of cultures
and all kinds of backgrounds
is only really
possible in my view
when there is arts
in the schools.
Because without art
programs in the schools
and the ability
to learn about it
and be motivated and inspired
by arts in the community,
it's nearly
impossible for people
to want to go into it, to have
the avenue to get into it,
and have any kind of
training to get into it.
So I think it's really
important to know
that when our arts are taken
away from school systems,
we're diminishing that.
We're not headed in the right
direction with that at all.
And the only way to
increase that direction
is to provide that understanding
in the schools at every level.
And I think that's something
that needs to be remembered.
CLAUDIA YANEZ: I would like
to add to that, because I'm
a product of an
arts high school,
and growing up in Miami,
it's super diverse.
But at the same
time, my first time
meeting a white blond person
was in high school in Miami.
And I moved there
when I was seven.
And also, it's just
being able to kind of--
I feel like that's
what made me get
into the arts is because I went
to school with people who were
so different from
me, people who were
from the clusters
of communities that
were like mostly Haitian or
African-American and stuff
like that.
And when we were
in the classroom,
we were all the
same, and we were
able to create work
together no matter
what you're like socioeconomic
background was and all
that stuff.
And so yeah, arts in
schools, very important.
CLAY OSTWALD: We like to talk.
SPEAKER 1: Arts
in schools, yeah.
So we actually have a couple of
minutes for audience questions
now, so we can open
it up to the floor
if anyone has any questions.
AUDIENCE: If you happened to
find yourselves in a technology
environment, what
technology advancement do
you think would make the most
difference for the theater,
have the most impact?
DANNY BURGOS: I only say
this because I was literally
thinking about it in
the wing last night.
So I was a spot op.
I was like a spot op
when I was in college,
because we had to do
like technical whatever,
and I was always thinking
about like how jarry I was
when I like moved the light.
And I was like, how
awesome would it
be if you could just
have a screen where
you put your finger on
whoever you're focusing on
and the spotlight just follows
them and it's so smooth?
And I was literally thinking
about that in the wing
while Gloria Estefan was singing
"Coming Out of the Dark."
[LAUGHTER]
CLAUDIA YANEZ: That
would be something.
CLAY OSTWALD: I
think that we all
have learned the importance of
technology in the arts world,
and some of us get
really into it.
I do as far as recording
and a little bit in video,
but mostly recording.
And we all understand the
importance of technology
in the media side of it,
but I think a lot of us
really focus 99% on the
creation of the expression
and not on the
technical side of it.
So that's, I think,
where our priorities are.
I don't know if that answers
you or hurts the question, but--
CLAUDIA YANEZ: I mean, just to--
I would think like
maybe a device
that would silence cell
phones automatically
in the whole theater.
CLAY OSTWALD: Ah,
there's a good one.
CLAUDIA YANEZ: Honestly,
it would be amazing.
Because sometimes,
like you're on stage
and you're in a dramatic
scene and it's like a silence,
and then you just hear like--
I don't know why "La Cucaracha"
is the first thing that
came to my mind.
That is horrible.
Anyway, but you just hear a
ring tone and you're like, eh,
and then you have
to block it out
and then it just takes
you out of the moment.
And so that would be beautiful
if there was like a device
that you could
install in the theater
and it just like automatically
silences the phones.
CLAY OSTWALD: That's a good one.
SPEAKER 1: I feel like that'd
be helpful at work too.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have any stories
about onstage or backstage
mishaps that have happened?
CLAY OSTWALD: Oh,
there are so many.
CLAUDIA YANEZ: I mean, yeah.
We were just talking
about this in the car.
So one day, I think we were in
Philly, and I was on for Gloria
and I had like 11 or 12 friends
and family members who drove
in or flew in to see the show.
And our opening
number, "Tradition,"
at the end of the
song there's a button,
you go ba-da-da-da-da-da-da,
que siga!
And one of our cast members
tripped me by accident,
and so it went
ba-da-da-da-da-da-da, fall,
que siga!
And Danny was like, how
did you hit the pose?
I was like--
DANNY BURGOS: She
hit the button.
CLAUDIA YANEZ: I had 11
people in the audience and not
to mention like 2,000 people.
I was like, there's no way that
I'm just going to be like--
DANNY BURGOS: If that was me, I
would've been like, stay down,
you're so embarrassed.
CLAUDIA YANEZ: Stay down.
It was not my
fault. I was like--
honestly, I didn't even
remember how I fell.
But that was one.
And then another time
we were in Chicago,
and I was on for Gloria.
And I was singing
"Anything for You,"
which is right at the
beginning of the show.
And at first, Gloria and
her sister sing it together
and they do harmonies, and
it's beautiful, whatever.
And then there's a part
where everyone kind of like
disappears into the
wings, and it's just
Gloria and her keyboard.
And she sings the whole song
and Emilio's like walking
around her being like, wow,
like she's so talented,
blah blah blah.
And so I'm playing, and
everyone is walking out.
And all of a sudden, the
whole music in the theater
just like cuts out, literally
no sound coming from the keys.
I can't hear the band.
I'm like, oh my God.
We're in Chicago, of course,
which is a huge theater town.
And I'm like, OK.
OK, this is great.
So I'm playing and I'm
kind of vamping, waiting
to see if they're going to stop
the show, because sometimes it
happens where a stage manager
will be like, guys, we're
stopping the show,
technical difficulties.
And the actors will leave,
then they fix it, we come back.
So I'm waiting because like
music, it's a Gloria Estefan
musical, it's important.
And then I realized,
I'm like, come on, guys.
Come on, come on.
And I kind of look
and I'm like, they
weren't going to stop the show.
So I had to do the rest of
the song a capella, which
was terrifying at the
moment, but also there
was a moment where I was
like, this is the best.
And it ended up being really
cool because when do you
get to do that?
Like kind of be in a theater
setting and just like--
and thankfully, like
towards the end,
I could hear like a little
bit of keys, but yeah.
It was crazy.
CLAY OSTWALD: OK, so I'll be
really quick with this one.
What you don't know is that the
entire time that was going on,
we have our earpieces
on and stuff.
We're playing along just fine.
We hear our
instruments just fine.
We don't know why she's
not singing with us.
We're like going,
what's wrong with her?
What is going on?
Why can't she hear us?
So it was a problem
with the house sound.
But we were like, why
is she so out of key?
Why does she sound so bad?
CLAUDIA YANEZ: No, no,
no, no, no, no, no.
I was singing in the right key.
CLAY OSTWALD: Not bad.
She sounded fine
to the audience.
CLAUDIA YANEZ: I was on a
different part of the song.
CLAY OSTWALD: She sounded
fine to the audience,
but she wasn't with us.
But the backstage
show, if you ever
want a really, really,
really entertaining night,
pay somebody to
sneak you in and sit
on the side of
the backstage area
and watch what
goes on backstage.
It's an entirely
entertaining show
like you'll never
see something before.
But one night in New York,
none of our moving automation
was working.
The entire computer system
was down, nothing was working.
We did the entire
first half of the show
with only hand props
and things that
could be carried on the
stage by the actors.
And they pretended like
the entire props were there
for the entire Act One.
SPEAKER 1: Oh my god.
CLAY OSTWALD: It was incredible.
It was unbelievable.
CLAUDIA YANEZ: Was
the kitchen automated?
CLAY OSTWALD: No, they
did the whole thing
without the kitchen.
They pretended
like it was there.
CLAUDIA YANEZ: Everything
was [INAUDIBLE]..
CLAY OSTWALD: It was automated.
Yeah, nothing was there.
The bed never came out.
She just acted like
her father was there.
Yeah, it was the
whole first act.
And it was old
school theater, you
pretended like it
was all happening
and the audience kind of got it.
SPEAKER 1: That's awesome.
CLAY OSTWALD: And then for
Act Two, it all got fixed.
SPEAKER 1: So the question
was, what song did you
sing for your audition song?
DANNY BURGOS: So I actually
came in with the Emilio packet,
so the first song that they
have us sing is "See Your Smile.
And I was dying of fright,
because you're singing
for the Miami Sound Machine.
You're just like,
hey, here's your song.
Hope you like it.
And then the director asked
me to sing one of the songs
from my book, and I sang
a song from the musical
called "The Last Five Years."
It was "Shiksa Goddess."
But yeah, and then after
that, they had me sing
"Don't Wanna Lose You."
And yeah, it's
just intimidating.
You are singing
their music for them,
and it's like
[CHUCKLES NERVOUSLY]..
CLAUDIA YANEZ: Yeah.
I also had the Gloria
packet, which is--
the audition packet
for the show for Gloria
is like 60-something pages.
It's so many songs
and so many scenes,
and I remember I had like
a week to learn everything.
But really, you know
that I knew this stuff
like two years in advance,
because I was like, put me in,
coach!
Put me in!
But yeah, it was scary.
CLAY OSTWALD: She did OK.
CLAUDIA YANEZ: OK, Clay.
Actually, I never sang for
Clay in any of my auditions.
No, I never sang for
you, because I auditioned
for New York for the most part,
so I only sang for [INAUDIBLE]..
CLAY OSTWALD: They sent us
a note saying we've already
approved her for her role.
We'll go on to the next ones.
Yeah, that's true.
CLAUDIA YANEZ: Literally, I
remember walking in and seeing
Clay the last time
they called me in,
and I was so excited to
sing for him because we
had mutual friends and
blah blah blah from Miami.
And I walk in and
I'm like, hey guys.
So they had me do this
scene that was literally
like three and a half seconds.
CLAY OSTWALD: That's true.
CLAUDIA YANEZ: I took
more time getting
ready for the audition than
what the audition actually was.
I walk in and I do the
scene, and I'm like, OK,
do you guys want
to hear me sing?
They're like, no.
I was like [SHRUGS SHOULDERS]
CLAY OSTWALD: Yeah,
we had a note.
She's already approved.
It was a formality.
It really was.
It was just a formality.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
So that's all the time
that we have today,
so thank you so much
for stopping by.
And if you haven't
checked out the show,
I highly recommend
you go check it out.
They'll be performing at
the Buell Theatre in Denver
until August 19 and
then heading off
to Costa Mesa in California.
Thank you for coming.
CLAY OSTWALD: Thank
you for having us.
Thank you for having us.
[APPLAUSE]